[Applaudissements]
christmas ça dans mon oreillette comme
c'est en régie influence sebaoun voilà
qui fait n'importe quoi à quelques
danses et voilà donc je les aime
beaucoup mais bon ce moment allait
surtout les mecs elle est partie à ibiza
la semaine dernière ses mythes
c'est la productrice de l'émission c'est
mykonos la semaine prochaine elle a
laissé en fait l'oreillette branché donc
j'entends comme un bon voilà tout le
truc je crois j'ai l'impression qu'à
nicolas hulot qui souffle dans mon
oreille voilà merci mais personne ne
fait rien résolu à la merci c'est ça la
france
non je sais plus quel est votre prénom
michel et jean michel jarre michel
gaubert bah je suis très content de
rencontre
toujours en concubinage avec la tunisie
bien sûr elle débarque lundi prochain
qui la tunisie une partie de la tunisie
l accord très bien ont régi vous
m'écoutez pas parce que vous n'arrêtez
pas en fait un merci bah si c'est pas
toi non parce qu'il ya florence maudit
mais c'est pas moi c'est dur pour moi
c'est toi
voilà pour moi c'est toi
avec moi ce soir
je voudrais tu auras tu viens avec moi
on va tous en résine
[Applaudissements]
bagis à la fille voilà ça chauffe dans
mon oreille des défis va les amener les
filles nées les filles avaient amené les
filles ramener les filles on va tous
aller au régime merci amener les pays
voilà voilà en régie ah mais oui mais
qu'est ce que tu as tué par balle qui
comment ça se fait que ça s'ouvre dans
mon oreille je veux des responsables
déjà il ya un gars là il a encore des
oeufs de pâques dans ses cheveux
non mais c'est bon alors qu'ils
s'occupent sais qui je veux c'est quoi
asselah
c'est là bas on va sérieux tout vous
montrer les gars on se fout de ma gueule
justin bieber c'est toi qui es en train
de mettre des trucs dans mon oreille
mais non non tu sais qui c'est qu'elle
sait justin c'est justin bieber sa faune
justin justin bieber et je te dis moi
alors il ya même un gardien pour le som
revêtent alors c'est difficile ici que
ne partent pas tous les sous ne touche
pas à mon poste
voilà vous savez les sons qui partent
bahamas et euh merci monsieur bien je
trouve
la et justin avait donc c'est quoi le
responsable ouais oui oui le sourire en
appuyant d'accord et pourquoi t'as pas
puis pour le son oui pourquoi devenue
championne d'asie alors voix a trouvé
que la vie à 27
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
ballan l'année je m'appuie sur le jeu va
payer sur le a les bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sois là que des musiques de merde en
fait à merde non merde c'est david
guetta revient demain mais non c'est
vachement bien parce que j'entends pas
dit si en fait je me fous dans la mer de
toi je me fous la merde je te le dis
merci en tout cas c'est super sympa
votre merci et vous savez j'ai toujours
le bordel demande alors est d'accord
merci
salut les gars merci de le passé qui
était qu'elle ait excuse moi quelle
heure il est ma chérie ah j'en sais rien
du tout il est dit il et 19h07 de
chaussures d'oreillettes d'eau merci
vous le voyez on est en direct alors
j'ai pas présenté tout l'autre côté de
la table dont de l'autre côté de la
table il ya gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
et il ya il s'indigne akela key les
bobos 10 à 1000 da
les séries on va se retrouver dans
l'instant on a plein de choses à faire
on va faire la patate chaude et dura
directeur du barbecue bien sûr dans le
bureau du